it's beautiful I thank you enjoy [__]
hey you said frig I'll wait a minute
like to propose a toast to my family
someday soon you're gonna have families
of your own and if you're lucky you
remember the little moments like this
that we're good
Cheers
I never stop worry bout a thing
when I was it shouting
the past part
hey buddies welcome back the good times
I'm Steve Simone I'm here in studio with
my pal mr. Lee saya hey Steve Lee what's
the name of your podcast flying jus
radio flying you radio and that comes
out when everyone's that everyone's day
I'm doing every week now that's awesome
it's safe and you also produce and
co-host the church what's happening down
with uncle Joey I do it's a lot of fun
and then this weekend oh wait the show's
already be over by the time we come up
with this podcast right well actually
though that it's gonna be a Sunday night
shows gonna be a Sunday night show so it
so if you guys are in vegas and you want
to see history hitam lee go to the south
point casino and see Joey tonight at
seven-thirty i believe it's a yes he's
filming it for a special friday and
saturday so now okay so this will be the
function now he'll be real loose and all
day and all fun but oh my god it's a
hopefully it hopefully it's been a very
exciting weekend oh it's gonna be that I
honestly think it's could very well be
one of those specials like bring the
pain or the Diceman cometh or the first
Kinison special like the type of thing
that launches Joey to where you should
be where look if all the comics in the
world know you're the best that says a
lot so now I'm just very happy for uncle
Joey that the world is going to catch up
to what we've already all known it's
very it's a exciting just to see it and
and see where cuz I've seen I'm lucky
enough that I get to go with him leaves
like once a week I'll go to the store
and see him to 15 minutes but I don't
get to see him do an hour very often if
not all that's what real comedy is like
the stores great i love it but being
able to rumble for 15 minutes versus an
hour it's a different thing and hours
what the real art form is in my opinion
everyone always gets jealous when when
they see like the posters of the comedy
store the comedy store lineup oh it's
incredible the thing that i miss the
most about living here are those our
long with a minute with an a future act
and then an hour along the headliner
yeah i almost think there's an enough
demand in what the city of Los Angeles
itself like I think comedy so hot right
now that if you had a little kind of owe
our style room 100 150 seats but you
rotated different hours every night
different MCS and different features you
would kill it yeah I think for me it's
where you really
a fan like you can like learn about
somebody as a store love that yeah
comics would love that to do an hour not
have to dry like on a Tuesday like just
to work it out and keep it fresh oh
that's well that's a good idea like the
whole week no all the time okay and have
you know looked like The Comedy Store
cycles up their lineups like same thing
with you you wouldn't have liked bill
burr five nights a week and pain to be
in town no be like this is a showcase
club style thing meaning different
comics every night right but different
amount of time every night to do think
there's enough comics to do that oh yeah
yeah everybody would do that I like
wouldn't that be cool like if downtown
LA there was a little 100-seat room or
you could see segura do an hour one
night and-and like Christina does a half
hour and then the next night they flip
it and it'll be gone he features for her
you know or you might have built Bardot
in 15 minutes just to grab a spot and
Neal Brennan doing an hour and uncle
Joey in the middle for a half an hour
that would be so cool I love it I think
it'd be right I wonder why there aren't
because to see an hour in LA you either
have to travel well there's the ice
house occasions ice house of occasional
flappers we'll have somebody mm-hmm and
then that's really it other than that
sometimes any in magic today do it what
now they do like a half hour a thing
I've never been there I've so nice I
would like to go see jay leno on a
sunday they do you want i would do that
with you what are you okay i want to do
a nerd comedy trip absolutely and my one
body works down and he's really nice and
he likes pro wrestling oh cool yeah so i
could probably he could probably get us
on the list that'd be so fun and and
then the improv does it occasionally yes
they do an hour occasionally like improv
two nights a week or something like that
right yeah i'll have a headliner come in
do you watch a lot of comedy as a
stand-up not nearly as much as I used to
um when I was a kid I loved it obviously
that's why I started to do it and then I
got to be and then a couple years ago
and we're getting really depressed and
like I was I lived really close to laugh
actory and I walked in there and I got
this he like amber seem like D'Elia go
up and my Kosta then I walked down to
the store and I saw like Moshe and I
just like wow I really have funny
friends and that cheered me up right
over then I tried to do the same thing
this summer and I got the press because
all the comedians were the same
I watched comedy for a while and
everybody was so filthy and they were
just talking about poop and sex
everybody every comic I saw and I was
like oh this is terrible speaking of
terrible ah good times is definitely not
brought to you by american airlines
still they are our anti sponsor and the
only reason i want to give you guys fair
warning about american airlines is
because they don't care about their
customers it would be kind of like i
don't want to sound mean but it's like
let's say if i went to a hamburger place
and they gave me instead of a hamburger
they gave me duty on a bun and I was
like excuse me I ordered a hamburger but
you gave me duty and they were like hey
that's what you get you paid for duty
and I'm like no I paid for a hamburger
like honestly if you went to a fast food
place and they gave you duty on your
sandwich you wouldn't want your friends
to eat there right right absolutely not
yeah so I don't want my friends to fly
american airlines because i'm like you
were reading off a copy but it's like me
and don't fly american airlines because
they don't care about the customer i
don't they really don't have you have
another issue just still i just want to
keep on reminding but like I honestly
view it like if I went to a hamburger
place and they gave me duty and I was
like excuse me I've been here many times
before and you always give me duty
instead of hamburgers and they wouldn't
give you a refund that we like store
credit I'd be like hey sometimes duty
gets in with our hamburgers and I
wouldn't even and I feel bad for
anybody's that are working for a mere
American just go find a better job man
especially what the game plan in work
you desert because what will happen is
people start associating you with duty
to see what they just did this past
weekend know a bunch of people tweeted
stuff at me like they sent the wrong
plane out or something this is
apparently for safety reasons since
there's no where they can land between
here in Hawaii mm-hmm they have to send
a certain plane that has certain safety
precautions and some safety things on
board in cases a fire or something yeah
and they sent a plaintiff had none of it
of course yeah they don't care and
apparently every plane that goes out
supposed to get signed by like the supra
this maintenance supervisor so they like
they had an anonymous quote saying
someone really far like it's not just
like a oh we happen to send the wrong
plane like it's it's they're supposed to
be checked multiple times yeah well they
probably honestly they're so cheap there
they probably don't pay people and they
probably look honest this is how i feel
about companies like
that if they treat their customers like
poop imagine how they treat your
employees oh it might not do not it that
awful like that maintenance guy could
have been like hey this is the wrong
plane and then someone at the Home
Office like well we can't know what it's
like I remember this is a true story
went into a diner when I was a little
kid what happened and that there was
duty in the urinal and I think it was
one of the cooks that did it and my dad
was like weird ever eat hero dead that's
his way I say it up yours that's how
they treat him so he's wants them to
treat that be if he stole that the
urinal what's he doing to your sand
wedge so we never went back to that
diner what do you think was the cook no
I think my dad saw what happened I think
I was so angry at the restaurant and how
he was being treated he was like I'll
show you I'll show you all take a poop
in the urinal hmm that's why that's Tara
one of the hardest times did your
headphone just go out yeah my just um I
think we're still I think it's still
good both favorite recording such as
headphones how come the hardest I ever
left was one time in a Wendy's bathroom
and there's this guy in a stall farted
in my friend and I were in the bathroom
and we laughed still makes me laugh I
had to one out of the bathroom laughing
sore cuz he's got happen to me at
Children's Hospital on Saturday really
it's still full blown growing up in this
guy but he was like he was in pain and
he and I ran out of the bathroom and I I
told all my body so I was like guys you
got to get in there it's the funniest
thing ever oh just the noise it was just
so funny actually I should Paolo for the
first time blazing saddles how did you
love it she liked it I was talking to my
mom and who by the way says hello and
I'll ease mom and she's like well when
you're a little when you're little
that's funny for everybody but it's
always gonna be fun for boys but not for
girls okay but I that just have the beam
scene with the farting the best still
makes me laugh just non-stop you know my
little buddy Steve and I he was like you
have to burp cuz I always act like I'm
gonna burp and then I go whoopsie wrong
end and he thinks it's the funniest
thing ever do you ask for all the time
because he still at that age was like do
it again do it again do it 20 more times
i'm gonna live it just a sec just as
hard
is that something you did for your for
your nieces and nephews you just figured
it up ram no just for him yep you know
you have to craft an act for each
individual little kid you're there to
entertain how did the blood drive go it
was just such a huge success site thank
you everybody that works so hard to make
that thing happen and all the people
that donated blood and such a good cause
yeah I was gonna say you sold out but I
don't even know the word is but that was
in those poor cow and couldn't that you
couldn't get in it that's pretty awesome
yep and Doc people like Doc Willis went
down even before the blood drive started
I'll jog is the best he is the best you
guys can just go to I don't even know
what their website is I should have that
all that I had it written down but now I
go but check it out and donate blood in
your town I mean people need it yeah i'm
i'm glad that it went so well and you'll
probably do him yeah i want to do it
over yeah and then there's another thing
i met the coolest kid down there this
kid William he's like a teenager okay
and he's battling leukemia and he's the
nicest kid in the world like he knows
everybody in the hospital because he's
healthy enough where he can walk around
he just can't leave the hospital okay so
I think he just finished around a chemo
and he was hanging out with Bret Ernst
so then Brett introduced me to this kid
William he's the coolest right so his
his buddies can't come visit him because
they live so far away but there's like
this little GoFundMe page that offset
like their travel costs and things like
that so he can have more people come
visit him okay if you guys are listening
I'm gonna tweet it out and put it on
facebook even if it's just a buck or two
just give it like everything
legitimately everybody's like well what
could I do to help you could give a
dollar everybody could give a dollar was
it the one that new tweeted yesterday
yeah okay that's pretty that's pretty
cool i just imagine him being the king
of the hospital just like he's the
cookie and then his buddy Alex at what I
went down I brought Chinese food to
those guys on sunday maybe and I had so
much fun I'm like oh I want to hang out
here all the time say no everybody it's
like hanging out with the coolest kids
in school I just imagine them walking
down the hall people are passing him
juice boxes yeah hey Jimmy overview like
Woody Harrelson in the beginning at
kingpin will just eat somebody else's
pizza oh that's so funny I'm glad it
went so well yeah it was awesome yeah I
can't
I just love it down there it's a really
cool place oh you know what else is a
cool place the Don Carlos taco shop
located in beautiful la jolla california
their website is eat a burrito com ask
for Ryan the next time here in San Diego
and you want a burrito I like making it
sound like we have real commercial or
tacos and tamales yes tamales are legit
I can't wait to get back down there are
you going soon no not to San Diego I
thought okay I don't know why I thought
you were going Mel hall or josh nelson
get me down there again or Comedy Store
but i think i'm gonna record a special
down there in january-february how cool
and then you are going Arizona I do know
that one oh yeah September 30th through
October fourth I'm gonna be in
scottsdale at like stand up Scottsdale
or something like that our house of
comedy rulings tin scottsdale I'm going
to tweet out the link for tickets
buddies already buying them up our
people making the drive oh that's so
cool yeah and then my one buddy sent me
money on paypal to see if we could get
Don Carlos to San burritos and he's like
if not we'll go out for burritos after
the show anyway I'm sure I wonder if
they would hold up just don't know no
shower cream oh yeah that'd be gross
well who do we have on this week this
week is one of my dis one my all-time
favorite people and this one of my
all-time favorite episodes of good times
Ryan Sickler from the crab feast the
guy's a world-class storyteller his
podcast is incredible that he co-hosts
with Jay Larson Jay gave me a verbal
that he's going to come on good time oh
cool and these guys the reason that why
their podcast is so awesome is they're
world-class storytellers and I got some
great laughs great stories out of
Sickler this is an instant classic you
guys are going to love this episode
check it out my boy Ryan Sickler
now he's policy time was a
let me sit yeah I'm don't I always I'm
always afraid I didn't record it it's
going thank you for being here oh it's
going now let's look at your face are
you just watching a mic Sickler oh we're
on we're like Larry and spaz under the
girls cabins if shits flash it or
whatever I don't know that equipment
yeah this thing's awesome well thank you
for having me here Steve summer thank
you for being here oh yeah dude I need a
good episode I need I need some of those
great stories could my dad's that body
of yours Rida kit for Baldy bore it will
start the exterior the extra syllable
and thank you for Baldy are you two
together forget it only more that is a
people play bball team or my grandma
used to say all the time sandy claws
claws use go to see Santa Claus was that
his [__] sister [__] sad ball
that's so funny yeah I missed that stuff
man mom's last time you were home gosh
the last time i was in maryland was
three years ago two years ago this would
be the 3rd yeah yeah once you have a
baby and stuff it's hard to get back
there do we got to get you back to
perform there you should be in baltimore
the last time i was there i performed
with Aisha Tyler and that was a lot of
fun but we're setting up jate you know
Jay just had his baby so congratulations
Larson congratulations Jason Larson I
can't wait to get him on here to keep
saying we're trying to do this and then
all this life stuff happens but row and
set up an East Coast run in Baltimore
would be one of the cities for sure that
would be in crime yeah we want to just
do some one nighters down from Boston
New York philately and then Baltimore
can see or maybe like right between
baltimore and DC yeah I gotta get back
to that part of the country I miss it
yeah jinx knock on wood I really
especially this time of year this is my
favorite time of year to be on the East
Coast yeah the humidity is gone it's
still in li like upper 70s may be right
around 80 it's perfect perfect that's
usually when I like to go back is sep
tember because I get an Oriole game
Raven game and you get that weather is
incredible you get out the Western
Maryland a little bit if you can you
start to see the large exchange and
stuff yeah Maryland's great little state
yeah I had a buddy that just moved back
what up at I had a buddy that job that
he's the best lynch mob but uh yeah I
just this I don't know there's something
about this time of year that makes me a
little nostalgic there's something about
this time here that whole back to school
thing makes me I have this like sort of
subconscious pressure to get my life
together I'm like all right bro summer's
over it's time to kick it in here I get
that I trapper keep not gonna get
liquored up tonight remember Farley yeah
like back-to-school shopping like okay
this is the ER I take my study seriously
I used to love back to school I would go
get like where's funny we're talking
about are we talking about this but um
you know we get like the trapper keeper
and then explain to the kids what a
trapper keeper so traver key right I'll
bet you they still make them on by
either store out there but you used to
have the binder which is the three-ring
binder it look like blue denim almost
yeah like a camel campus cloth over like
industrial cardboard and then everyone
would take it make it theirs what they
write their favorite bands on it or
whatever the [__] they wanted to do get
a sign the van Halen vh is very big from
your generation so uh and easy ones to
like twisted sister I think a lot of
people did that they weren't even
Twisted Sister fans or just like I can
do that team so then it then it was it
became like a trapper keeper compared to
that binder was like the x-games of
binders you know I like it went from
just a thing that opened up with three
rigs at it to this [__] slides you got
pockets and zippers and you're like oh
my god but it was one thing that had
individual folders for each class and uh
it was just a lot going on at velcro
clothes not [__] fell out because you
remember that man your papers would
start falling out you're like always I
will never forget there was a fight okay
so it was a girl fight we uh ninth
grades the only year I rode the bus
after okay so six seven eight
we were walkers okay okay he sounds like
a zombie moon walkers all right I and i
loved it i was my favorite thing I've
written I it these two say when they
would let you go they would say the
first thing was walkers are dismissed be
like so yeah everybody's waiting for
their buses yes and it was always one
kid yes you're so riya you're out for
different dismissal times yup remember
it like bus 88 bus 88 and someone said
to me like could you just leave if you
wanted to I go yeah but you're getting
on bus 88 acid those bus drivers know
every kid on that bus yeah and if you're
not supposed to be on that bus and you
do sneak on you're going you have to
call your mom blow any more like I'm on
the wrong by oh my god to leave school
oh my god they ever feeling you got on
the wrong bus crow like that I don't
know I don't know that house I don't
know that house where's mr. Johnson
scarecrow like I knew the Halloween
decoration do supposed to be going that
way so walkers are dismissed and we will
be out and we would laugh because you
just picture 6 7 8th grade I don't know
how many hundreds of children that is
but mathematically there will be one
who's the last out or ham and we're
already long gone home playing already
yeah and our principal we said this
principal named mr. chase he's an older
black dude he was the vice principal and
he's to have a wooden paddle on his wall
on with holes in it he was just all
about intimidation though he was the
sweetest [__] guy yeah he was and we
would say what what's that for mr. chase
a s when you spank somebody to the meat
sucks through it we're like oh my you
know I hope mr. chase is listening
somehow mr. chase is still alive and
well I see him on facebook pictures he
also as we got older in the high school
and stuff he was a referee for soccer
and football style anyway see it was a
great dude and we would see him we'd
like but he was old school you know we
like what's up mr. chase me don't call
me mr. chase now after the game I'm the
ref right now hi chase
because he didn't want a big you know
all these kids he didn't know say we're
calling a mr. chase and [__] he's like a
man don't look like favoritism out here
you'll get me in trouble yeah so um I
just saw like a teacher who I'm friends
with on facebook i posted a picture of a
bunch of our old favorite teachers now
currently oh and he was in there and
yeah he was oh no someone asked about
him and I guess he's like at one of the
heads of the Board of Education and
stuff in that area now his domus yeah it
was the best but he had an old Cadillac
a blue sedan everything about this guy
fantast and uh it was and he right away
what he would do as soon as walkers were
dismissed he would get in his Cadillac
and he would just drive their
surrounding neighborhoods because he was
looking for fights or anything he was
out patrol now the reason I'm saying
this is because it's there any children
not behaving properly that's not even do
duty police that they run himself it was
like he was like lean on me but it's his
car jeffer that big daddy kane remix i
would watch over TV around with my jaw
open waiting for it at the way Lean on
Me Lean on Me my stepson uh was leaving
school the other day and there was this
two kids were fighting on school
property and there was a crossing guard
there so she went to get to pull a
teacher or no no a teacher salt went to
go get the principal in the crossing
guards telling the kids so they were
like well [__] this they went to a
church parking lot right across the
street and me and there's a crossing
guard trying to tell like 30 middle
school kids don't go over there watch
that fight and they're all oh yeah
you're not oh yeah so he's telling me
about it and that's what made me think
of it I said oh we used to have a middle
school cuz he's a walker now and we were
walkers in middle school so I'm telling
what it was like casa me walkers and I
said our vice principal because there
are there were fights there were always
a lot always those doors I call like
ages 3 4 to about 8 to glory years and
then like 11 through like 14 15 or the
chaos years yeah it was goodbye seventh
grade was still of all the years of
school is one of my favorite years I
left really where I very start you like
have other friends that laughed and
wrote and did the sort of shadow
but um so he would like drive these
surrounding neighborhoods and stop these
fights or try to catch them before they
started and stuff and there were always
some girls like mr. chase they're
fighting over on thurs dreamlike thanks
girl and I'm just imagining the hooding
the siren on his car I got it like but
the thing was he's babe with zero regard
for anyone else in the neighborhood to
keep walking he's Florida like trying to
get there to break up he would it was
like you were his kids so he was the
I'll be damned he was laughing his kids
I don't you know what I don't know
that's a good question I bet you it just
sounds like he's so involved in the
community it's like how could he
implicate wasn't letting you get out
into that neighborhood and make that
school look bad he wasn't doing it he
was on that she I hope people still care
yeah he was on that [__] he was a great
vice principal so is this the girl fight
that he's flying to somebody told him to
he said there was a girl fight see I got
way off track thank you for bringing me
back to girl for a girl fight completely
separate I was all so in elementary
school whatever we took buses 6 7 8th I
was a walker and then ninth grade I was
on a bus until 10th grade was license 10
11 12 the coke oh you had oh yeah cool
mortgage I got mine in March so ninth
and half of and a little half of 10th I
was on bus and this one particular day
were on a bus this goes back to that
three ring binder the the old school
canvas one the Jay Leno I will call it
that's what he wears at denim on denim
on denim it was like sarah Jay Leno
binder so um these two girls are on the
bus and one girl starts talking [__] to
a guy we know and she's just just
ripping him up and down and she starts
punching him on the bus and he's doing
nothing he knows he can't hit a girl
back he's not even saying anything but
she's [__] laying in on him so he's
just like what the [__] like somebody
want you help me out a little bit so she
gives him a couple shots because what it
is is he's gonna fight her friend this
guy say get off the bus and they the the
guy we know and her friend guy friends
start fighting okay and he our guys on
top of her guy and he's punching him in
the face
and she goes around behind him and she
winds up like she's like she's kicking a
67-yard [__] field oh my god and she
kicks him our guy in from the back like
he's on top of the guy like think of
doggystyle kicking him in the balls oh
and I mean it was a thud like a like it
hit a football for see like it was good
to one line right at eye and he we just
heard him he screamed and rolled off and
yelled somebody get hurt please make a
t-shirt but just says somebody get her
like please oh my god cuz he was like
please somebody [__] her up also please
somebody get her don't let her do that
again I'm the worst pain I've ever met
he just said haha somebody get her oh
man the dude got away and she got away
so the next day on the haul had to be
war next day on the bus my neighbor
Shannon she was she was a very cool
chick um I've never met a chick named
Shannon that wasn't cool he was cool and
she walked up to that girl on that bus
and said I saw you [__] hit him on
this bus yesterday it's on and then I
saw you kick him in the [__] balls
unfairly yesterday and she said he's not
going to hit you because he's a
gentleman but when we get off this bus
I'm gonna [__] you up and this girl had
glasses on and Shannon gave her just a
jab to the right to this right here
right center of the nose and like
crooked made her glasses crooked and
stuff and that girl like started crying
oh man she not only that like it was a
solid like she knew what she was doing
there's more of this coming after we get
off this ha-whump Irish brothers like if
you think I'm even Joe she's turning
that fist overthrowing a little hip into
it do this making noises like everyone
Apollo Creed reverie what Apollo Creed
has hit in the coordination bag
tomorrow oh my gosh that's one of my
favorites to like go to Dan town possum
mm-hmm oh Jesus no he said no there was
no yeah so she [__] turned it over
and gave my poo a sting right in the
face and was like I'm gonna go sit my
seat back here it's tape on that cuz
it's about 15 minutes for we get to that
bus stop ha ha Ryan she's scared so we
get off the bus now everybody there's a
couple people getting off a stop or two
ahead you know what I mean they will
walk a mile we want to watch this
[__] fight why we were interesting
little nugget for you here so you know
the movie crybaby the John Waters moves
I know I'm aaaaa so that movie had our
high school band in it they shot it in
this little town where we went the
school right out there in Maryland
Carroll County Maryland and they used
this church they called the Chatterbox
orphanage well that church was the
church that this happened in like what
the story I'm telling you right now you
can go to that movie pause the like you
know wide shot establishing shot of
chatterbox orphanage of this church and
look and see exactly where what I'm
telling you happened on this piece of
property that bus stopped right there we
all get off the bus and then you know
she lets the bus get into the distance
and she grabs this girl the girl had big
boobs too and she beat she [__] her up
like a dude I mean she had two older
brothers who probably man she fought her
like a guy beat the [__] out of this
girl and while she was doing that my
buddy who had had been kicked in the
balls took her little three-ring canvas
binder and took her papers out and just
threw it was windy he threw every
everything one in the air and it was a
cemetery behind it I guess I was like a
movie yet so the was in one so the wind
catches all her papers and they're
everywhere and she pulls her shirt open
for guys and stuff like that she's a
young guys want to see her boobs I mean
two girls follow that bad or that bad
like it was three shots but the girl
just went down she knew she just
basically was like it was like a Bronx
tell them I'm gonna say before and now
you leave and she's like don't you write
out of somebody it's gone yep don't you
ever [__] do that again I'll bet
girl never interfere with anybody's
business ever again wow that's great i
remember watching a girl fight when i
was in it was in middle school cuz I
remember it I and I remember these two
girls and there's sometimes difference
between girls and boys like say eighth
grade there could be women in eighth
grade and these were two women based
grade women fighting and I remember
legitimately being scared yeah I
remember like I remember like I think I
was like in 6th grade I think they were
like a year or two older than me but
developmentally I was like one of those
little kids wearing a Hawaiian shirt
like a nobody give me the business I'm
gonna make soda come out my nose it's
cuz you're jealous you're just jealous
of this shirt well I remember the girl
punching the other girl and she you know
like how sometimes in cafeterias when
you're lying to get your hot food they
have those us partitions like uh like a
let's not Stanton's it's not polls it's
like when you go through a Corral like
it all your the terminal or something
yeah those turnstile things but then it
just runs the so kids would stay in line
the tray like all the way around that
metal yeah but then the thing on that
right keeps you next to that thing like
I forget I don't even know what the i'm
a [__] but anyway this girl gets
punched over that oh it was like ah it
was like a prison movie officially hit
her way cafeteria oh my god and I'm were
just being like this shouldn't happen at
school like it was such a vicious
beating I got scared yeah chicks chicks
or no joke no they're not I'm just
sitting here talking to my to Derek
about that as my stepsons names like say
derek about fights in school and stuff
and I said you know he said the kid that
was he's they said he wasn't really a
bully but he just talked [__] to
everyone he was always better than you
and I'll beat your ass and I'll be here
is and this one little kid got tired of
hearing it and I guess that guy pushed
him and that kid said [__] it you you
know you don't know I told Derek like I
wish someone would I said this to me to
like you don't know what somebody else
is going through now you don't know if
their grand mom just done are their
mom's going through breast cancer I got
[__] you might just catch the eye
somebody on a bad day
add [__] day you know seventh
grade or not that little thing if spark
plug goes off and it's you're the same
size it could be trouble and it was he
took this kid down they said he stomped
his leg and broke it my ambulance showed
up and I was talking about fights I
remember middle schools seventh grade we
were in science class there was this kid
named Ronnie of course he was the piece
of [__] and there was a kid named Sean
and Sean was a big quiet kid big like
Country Strong be like oh lineman yeah
yup and and quiet and you know also shy
in a way yeah and he never talked and
ronnie was sitting behind him in science
class flicking his ears and [__] with
him and the kid turn around told him
don't stop touching me stop nudging me
in the science teacher she heard it and
she said hey stop knock it off and the
kid kept doing it in the kid kept doing
it and then class was over and before
we're going to our next class he said
something else to the kid and he came up
and pushed him and I mean you just saw
this instant rage in this quiet kid and
he reached back and man he [__]
crushed his kid in the face knocked him
unconscious like even the science
teachers like oh cuz she saw him he had
that looked like a boxer like where the
[__] am I and he went down and she went
and got mr. chase the way I'm imagine
mr. Chancellor that would paddle yacht
is hidden like a cob like around that
he's actor / on it like dissertation
pursuit my way mr. chase on pursuit lean
on me lean on me man EK EK running oh
man and the truth was I mean you know I
told Derek like if you fight back you're
going to get in trouble too yeah but I
don't know how it is today but that day
even the science teacher said he
bothered that kid the whole class the
kid told him nicely I told him multiple
time and he put hands on the kid and the
kid crushed him and mr. chase is like
that's what you get Ronnie that's what
you get and took him down and he's like
you know he had to tell Shawn to you
can't do that I can't approve of that
but his punishment was not as severe as
the kid that
ended up getting [__] [__] up and I
told Derek like that those are lessons
you don't you know you can you can learn
that lesson by seeing it happen to
somebody else sure you don't have to
learn that by now happen to you like
can't be that [__] so yeah there was
a lot of fights we had those years
especially right yeah that's cool I mean
not just a you know I've talked about
this on on the crab feast and there's
been a great podcast buddies you have to
listen to these we have great episodes
but Maryland I mean that whole area is
just an angry area yeah you know we had
riots in May obviously it's an
aggressive area it just isn't DC but I'm
not like me yeah it's just it's a
different thing and III I think it has
to do you know life is just tough man
life is tough for everybody yeah and I'm
not saying just black people or knows
white people I'm talking about like the
fights we had all of more white people
yeah you know what I mean all of them
and there were a lot of fights I watched
one of the scariest there were two
scariest two fights I've ever seen one
was a Preakness it's just that's and the
other one I mean these are both like a
1a and 1b for different reasons but i'll
start with the other one first so I went
back to Baltimore to visit my brother my
brother and a buddy of ours were living
in a house in can okay okay and then her
little row home and you know it's just
Brooke just home home home home Oh house
out but there's a bar like two blocks up
on the corner and we're out and it's
winter and the sidewalks are you know a
little bit icy and it and while you fall
on that hard onto your ground track your
[__] head you're done you're done so
we're standing outside people were
inside hanging out we're outside smoking
and we just see this crowd I've never
seen anything like it empty out of this
bar maybe 20 or 30 people come just like
sprinting out together but they're all
fighting I like holy [__] and we're
watching it well then Here Come 20 more
and Here Come more
oh my [__] fighting and it doesn't
look like anyone is on any one side it
just looks like everyone is every man
for himself yeah and it starts coming
down the street toward us and now
there's people coming out of their
houses and [__] looking and their get it
it was a it was an absolute mob it was a
very definition of a [__] mob and you
see people putt and they're coming off
cycle on here come all these [__]
police pulling around and [__] and there
were just a bunch of drunk [__] that
we're still standing you've seen these
dudes in philly before they'll just
stand right near him and just stare at
in stuff and they'll to circle and try
to talk you're just waiting for him to
do something and we just called
everybody in the house like come here
come out here and then they would leave
my cousins a cop he had up a couple of
friends was like keep running up and
down this street tonight for a little
while it was crazy I've never seen
anything like it scary when at it yeah
when fights are real there's nothing
cool about it not especially something
like that and and the one out there
preakness was the scare it was scary as
[__] but the mob thing like justice my
everybody moving on down the street like
like it wasn't like it was in like this
like organism that we're growing and
moving I was like holy [__] it's like it
had a mind of its own it was not some
never say anything like that but at
preakness this is my last trip to
preakness to UM this one time this last
time was me both my brothers and then
two of my cousins three of my cousins
two brothers and a sister they're like
third cousins but we gave up like you
guys they were all still super close I
talked to him all the time awesome so we
go and you know back then used to be
able we used to take like a you know the
big garbage can recycle ones with wheels
yeah yeah absolutely oh just we are all
around the infield with us wherever we
went we just had beer drinking like it's
like the 1970s sir Sir you know you can
tell you can basically tell a lot about
someone when especially in their 30s and
40s when you're done all you drink event
and you have to drink as much as you
[__] it you know what I mean you tell a
lot about a person
and when it's all you can drink they
take that [__] to heart and go for it
yeah that's a very East Coast thing
where it's like people all you can drink
means i'm going to try to break the bar
and pass out and throw up as opposed to
like oh I can have fun yeah people don't
drink that have fun they normally you
have to maybe I'll have three maybe four
now now that if 19 20 yeah it's crazy
writes all you can drink man yeah but
Saul you literally could drink you
[__] bastard out all poison did I
don't miss my 20s at all so um we go to
Preakness and they change the rule from
that because people it's a hundred
thousand people to pack on that infield
which is insane and they're all that
[__] up i mean i went with people what
you do is you'd get a bus a school bus
people get on school bus they'd all pay
a fee the bus would drive you bus sits
there in parks and it's an all day thing
like you get there at 8am that main
Preakness race the one that's part of
the Triple Crown is until 5pm and what
time two people get a 281 Escott you're
drinking on the bus down okay so you're
drinking like 7 a.m. okay and there's
tags in the bus everybody's party and
you got to just suck it up and go you
know that if you're on a bus with 40
people aw it's all 40 of you aren't
staying together all day not to k I mean
like it's absolute chaos you should
write a movie where it all just takes
place over the pre-k to the People's
Park not something to feel heavy metal
parking lot you ever see that movie
course one of my favorite that was
Marilyn that was all caps enter have you
just I play here's the things I play
when i watch heavy metal parking lot
games I've invented for myself find the
Camaro or count the Camaro or camaro
style body like the berlinetta [__]
cows count the black people in it I
think there's a total of under-five and
other security guards there might be one
fan um the teeth looking at those teeth
just count those you'll probably get the
12 total um I play the little those
games are great i ever delivered yeah it
is pretty
our day like Google heavy metal parking
lot it's hilarious a cult classic so
we're uh we're now inside and some
people are tripping on acid some are
taking shrooms online I never understood
that because it's right when it starts
getting hot you know memorial day like
around there yeah and some days are
hotter than others some years and I just
never understood been out in the Sun and
on acid and I'm not many people around a
hundred thousand people for for the
whole trip I mean you're there all day a
lot of people are passed out before the
[__] main race is really sad like I
remember adults trying to communicate
this to me when I was like say 22 and
you can't take a 40 year olds brain and
put it in 22 it's that [__] life
shouldn't really work like that yeah
there it got as a plan at all bounces
out like you can recover faster there's
all these when you're younger but the
level of sadness you must have to get
that wasted like I was sad in my 20s and
i would get wasted but it also was a
function of youth like I number one of
the first jokes I ever wrote was a the
same behavior that made me cold 18 at 28
was a cry for help like you don't even
like if you light a fight take a drink
get naked start a fire at a party when
you're 18 you're the coolest like you
see Stevie's outside it's got a shirt
off and I was like what if you do that
at your nieces second birthday party
people praying for you behind your back
like you see Steve he hasn't shared get
the rosary yeah get to Rosario but there
are people back home and I'm sure it's
out here to doing that yeah like
thirties forties fifties still drinking
your soul is fighting in your 40s nom
there is like if you're not defending
yourself or your family you can [__]
job that gets wrong doing drugs so sad
so you know these people that but that's
what this event is for it's for all
those people you know that want to just
get hammered like that there's a hundred
thousand of them yearly that want to
pack in there and do it and you know
they sell shirts that say horses there
were horses because there are people is
a giant party walk by noon there people
laying face down vomit all around and
yeah they're done for the day they're
done got a day
yeah someone now has to babysit them if
they have a good group of friends so um
you're bringing up so sparking sodium
are not like a man's ass old man so I
was gonna I was at dude so many times we
would never have seen me like that I
roll you're gonna sunburn that's all
might know as given if we did we would
draw like a dick on your stomach or
something that would burn in there Oh
feel that all song so you know and they
also did to a good friend of mine i was
telling he works for the ravens he also
worked for Pimlico is the track where
this dude's got the best life everything
that goes to try he's an electrician for
Pimlico was the track where Preakness is
and if you've ever seen its own they did
a piece on tosh point-o but they call it
the running of the urinals so there's
just urinals side by side by side by
side by side because they sorta potty
line so many people though the spot upon
stuff well drunk idiots had started
getting up on top of them and sprinting
across them all the way to see if they
can make it of course while these drunk
idiots are getting it more wet and more
wet people were throwing beers unopened
beers and crushing them some open beer
so now it's getting wet and dangerous
they're all falling off and they did it
for two years and then my buddy's job
the next year they had a company vida de
guile is it for Preakness this year
let's separate those journals so yeah 3
and then a big-ass gap and three more so
that people couldn't just sprint across
the tops of them yeah some people get
hit in the head and [__] you can watch
the videos on youtube and just they're
getting crushed by beer cans and
whatever anybody wants up throw at them
while they're going across could he
thinks the bigger [__] the person
running on top of them throwing stuff
that's tough call of it that's a tough
call it is do you remember like your
first party where there was beer yeah I
do we are parties remind me to come back
to the Preakness fight story oh no
wonder that what you that now I'm just
thinking of our parties we used to go to
house parties that would get someone
would always call we firmly believed we
had an ARCA nor
when and we we did 20 min once I agree
and we had in the ninth grade my high
school was you they were still smoking
lounge oh yeah and parrot all the heavy
metal kids turn out that's exactly where
the denim would be yup and then I'm
patches and I patches mangu and [__]
yeah um bandanas that yep bandanas uh
they if you were 18 you could you didn't
have to have your parents permission but
if you were a senior that was a under 18
if you're still 17 at the time they had
to sign for you and some parents really
game I kickin smokin school so there was
a room and it was just ridiculous
because you would come around this
corner of the hallway and it was just
this [__] cloud a [__] smoke well
obviously the next year they got rid of
that [__] and then everyone just smoked
in the bathrooms and stuff you know just
pouring it in and our school was a bad
school for drugs in the ninth grade a
they used two days to come through and
check lockers and stuff like that so by
what you know 10th 11th 12th people are
you know party we would do field parties
if we couldn't have a place and that was
always fun but the house party we as we
just assumed this is our you know high
school mind like there must be an arc
because every house party we go to it
gets [__] busted the Maryland State
Police pull up and they come in and
stapley in troopers state troopers cuz
staties buddy you keep her mouth shut
but Crockett have with a nightstick and
you know what that's your own goddamn 0
God their problems i'll do that they
address you yes sir yes officer no sir I
apologize for beaded [__] cuz my dad
taught me better but I want to be [__]
spongebuck NZ showed off for my buddies
good I want to be [__] showing off I
pick up hot [__] I can't run a 40-yard
dash in under five seconds so i got
impress everybody by guzzling beer like
an [__] my dad would break my balls
that's but he's a hundred percent right
now is 104 samurai lover he's throwing a
knot in from self you make sure you tell
the police my dads [__] my dad told me
[__] is it was contagious and I'm a
carrier of [__] ism that's awesome
man so we were so sure of it and we also
lived there was a state trooper barracks
right by our high school so that's why
it was always state troopers they were
right there in the [__] neighborhood
and they would come in the house looking
to arrest people and weed sprint out
into the woods or where backyards and
whatever we could to get the [__] out of
the house and it always happened and
there was one kid that that we were so
sure collectively as a group that was
the NARC did he have a beard I beat him
up yes I tried to beat him up they try
to beat his ass again so we were like
[__] after that go really I want to go
back and look and seriously the guy that
you suspected was an art got beat up by
his student got attempted to get someone
wanted to beat his ass cuz they were so
sure he was an R cos every party we went
to I was at two parties to for a fact
that this guy was at then he left to go
on a beer run or whatever and then when
he came back with beer which he probably
got [__] because he's 25 yeah um the
police had already been there and busted
the house and left and then here he
comes like what the phone everybody two
times I saw that so one time at the
party someone [__] tried to attack
imma beat the [__] out up and he never
showed up to school and then up maybe he
did I just don't remember i love these
cloudy high school member i would love
to go look for a senior yearbook to see
if he actually ate out graduated he'd
have what's it what's the high school
what's the graduating it will put it out
there and see if somebody can find it
why have to say his name and I don't
wanna say Sam right yeah you don't want
to blow up the spot in case well I don't
know peter deluise was his name what was
his character's name um 21 Jump Street
forgive peter deluise with tremendous
jump down on Jump you were so sure he
was 21 Jump Street we were sure that
[__] you know what's crazy to me about
my high school memories sometimes when i
try to remember stuff i remembered
through the mind of a 16 year old does
that make any and course that's when you
have you processed it look like I I was
living with my younger brother was the
happiest I've ever been as a grown up
and we would talk about stuff like was
the greatest would always try to write a
movie script and then it would just turn
in the family therapy memory lane kind
of like this podcast a number once we
were hanging out and we were talking
about different ways to get to my
grandmother's house that like we would
drive to get butter puffs like don't you
remember that place where we'd get the
meatball sandwiches you make a left by
storybook land and you go right and I'm
like what it was like down by for that
because there was a theme park named
storybook land yeah we have one called
enchanted forest right but my little
brother was like legitimately he's like
30 years old he's like remember what
Humpty Dumpty lived and I'm like mark
what did you just say he was a queer
Humpty like in his brain there really
was a place where all these characters
lived then he had to go back and process
it as a 30 year old be like yeah what
the hell am I talking about cuz we would
just drive by woods and people be like
that's where Goldilocks is with the
three bears oh yeah there was a junkyard
there was a legit junk you come over the
plat street bridge to get in the philly
the other bridge was backed up and there
was a junkyard right there and I used to
think Fat Albert lived there i'd be like
I wave to him and [__] I thought that
was the fat yeah I didn't know that's
great and it's even funnier with the
height of each turn the radio down I
think they're playing a junkyard band
man so great playing the [__]
radiator yeah squeeze in it and [__] so
you thought you had a narc your parties
must have been cool thing we had we had
we had good parties and then you know
when my my father died when we were in
10th grade and then my we ended up in
this apartment alone my mom just went
and lived with her boyfriend while the
three of us stayed in this apartment for
you know two and a half years he should
write a TV show about that I know like a
netflix TV show comedy with that shows
by the way I agree mama and comedy
wonder your style yup one ears is great
God we so we lived in this house and we
had just the only way for us to cope was
to be around our friends yeah and we
were good kids I think that's pretty
much a as all we had that's all we all
have you know if but I mean literally
when your dad dies and then your moms
like you guys can stay here I'm gonna go
be somewhere else yeah we have each
other and then especially those years to
enzos your friends are everything I mean
we're still friends with so many of
those people's is that awesome it's
awesome there is some so much truth to
that like these tough times you go
through bro they make the most beautiful
relationships the most beautiful mama
don't runs with middle school people
yeah big time there we go v1 they can
Brian it's nice to when we go to
weddings and [__] and everyone shows up
other people like the other people that
aren't from our side you know the
bride's side or whoever it is they all
come over to us and be like you guys
known each other since sixth grade
really up there like that's a mate
they're always blown away by that we're
all still friends and still tight and
stuff yeah that's awesome yeah I forgot
what I was saying we were talking about
the high school parties the beers and
then you were like 10th grade you're in
this apartment just hanging out with
your friends so we would have everyone
just come to our place because there was
zero parental supervision and we were
good kids people like I still talk to
all those people I say to them they all
have kids I'm like hey would you allow
your son or daughter together like they
don't even let me finish nope nope even
though we never got arrested or did
anything it's just like I just want to
remember Gary it is scary but but for a
kid that's going through that like they
would let him spend the night on Monday
nights we've always went to school I
remember a friend of Mines wife said to
me she goes wait a minute you had no
parental supervision went to school
every day yeah she goes good kids I go
and I went to college she goes you're an
idiot I thought about it for a second i
was like huh i could have probably taken
a day a week off or whatever i could
have if i wanted to but but you know
what it was we wanted to make sure it
was our dad who looked good you know
what I mean like he taught us better you
know what I mean like yeah like my dad
did teach is better like you're not
going to be some slack or pieces of [__]
you're going to [__] school you're
getting an education if you have to do
it yourself you're [__] doing it you
know all honestly that knowing how
difficult my parents life was to try to
instill in us values that's why like now
the older I get the more I appreciate
everything number one but like I'll hold
the door open for people I'll
somebody if they need help alka help so
carry something to their car to the
point where people think I'm a lunatic
they're like what I'll go volunteer time
somewhere because it's like that's how I
honor my parents I'm like you know what
I I can't thank them enough for doing
without to make sure we had something
for working an extra job to make sure we
had a roof over her head but i can try
my goddamn best to be a good person yeah
you know that's it I've learned that too
because I grew up extended family like
grandmothers and great aunts and still
are so influential and they were older
so I always grew up learning respect on
that not only my parents age but their
age absolutely adore you that lady over
there needs help you go help her I still
to this day I used to go to my so my
gret my dad's mother my grandmother
lived right outside the city and we
ended up living with her after we got
out of high school my mom kicked us out
my brother my twin brother and I kept my
little brother but we live with her and
not far from her was another great aunt
on my mom's side who dick couldn't stand
my mother and loved like well thats all
hardcore italians and she was just
always she was the aunt mary she was the
[__] best like my mom's mom my
grandma on that side was great too she
loved me but she wasn't warm and
inviting like my dad's mom was right she
was the one that was just like that's
grandmom yeah grandmom devito you know
absolutely absolutely grandma you say
grandma you know which grandmas are
absolutely i'm out devito yeah so but
grandma devito had a sister named Aunt
Mary this is my great aunt she was old
and she lived in Baltimore County and
she'd had this little house where she
refused she's one of those old
hard-headed italia's refused to use a
walker in her home mm-hmm but what she
did was she would set up lawn chairs all
the way to the front door so she'd walt
and gravel oh my god that is so adorable
i did see her that's so adore about the
cutest thing i've ever heard so I've
come to the door I'd all we have seemed
like this stuff Valentine's share this
with all that stuff I'd go take flowers
to her all the time like
I love she would always say she had our
back she couldn't stand that her mom had
left our family and just abandon us and
she would she'd always do this she go
people take care of their dogs better
than she takes care of her kids I was
always her life and yelled that dog play
with everybody and Mary I'm just
imagining for whatever is it i'm
imagining Pachino in drag you could you
know what Pacino be like figure in a
scent of a woman where is like he's a
good boy I love when people would stab
so much emotion exhaust and it closed
out of them she couldn't get over it she
was a mom she couldn't get over it so
she extra loved us you know what I mean
she extra loved us so and they were
always the two better way Helen all
those let all my aunts and stuff they
always try to give you like a little 20
when you leave they just keep the bulla
bug boy ah Sookie so Aunt Mary would
have those lawn chairs and so you get to
the door you Blake what's up and i'd
always surprised she called me Wray Wray
she goes oh and she bakes and not have
to watch her chair damn bear chair to
chair Jerry I'm just imagine the
sunshine this guy keeps up get lower and
lower by the time to get super water and
married all right oh man I used to go
over all the time and what you cook for
you she'd always have something ready
all right and all ain't grandma was the
best yeah mm-hmm that's a tough I you
know what's crazy when I meet girls that
I date I go she gonna be a cool lady
right she gonna kiss me hug honey are
like all my god you're gonna be
somebody's grandmom one day in a problem
I'm gonna be around but we're gonna be a
[__] grandmom one day it's awesome oh
so it is your goal as a dad like what do
you think makes uh cuz you're a deep
thinker good dude well my goal was a
father is to be in my daughter's life
just to be their number one to show up
physically emotionally mentally and the
other thing too is to teach her all of
my mistakes you know teach her
everything I know and then instill in
her a work ethic and a drive
a happiness and you know a loving caring
kind person who then goes and does way
better than I have ever done and thinks
way deeper than I ever had and becomes a
way better person than I ever could be
parent whatever because i think that is
your goal as a parent is then give them
everything you can to teach them you can
be more and smarter and and then I want
her to pass that on to you know my
grandkids and so on and so forth that's
my goal as a father and also to to be I
say to be around like I need to take
better care of myself with eating and
[__] like yeah last year I just been
going the easy route because it's been
all sleeping and this and that order in
and [__] like that like I need to get
back into myself and physically stick
around cuz my dad died at 42 which is my
age now and yeah I'd be pissed if I died
right now say but so short it's just
starting to figure it out but back to
having all these these parties at our
house in tenth grade so you know once
you're it's great for everyone else
because they don't live there but we
live there so we're there
twenty-four/seven and we get tired of it
we be like hey who's having a party this
weekend we'd like to get out of our
[__] house and go yeah so these dudes
have won one night and we all got there
this is before cell phones and pay all
that [__] so we remember that like just
trying to find where this party is yep
my god that with somebody's house
tonight win a pair and we don't know I'm
start looking for cars and you're like
that's Ronnie's car that Ronnie's car no
it's got to be close here ha ha tinh
dong and like pro weird if we have
football players are you guys broke
football players are working the door
see senior football players are working
the door oh my god yeah i'll tell you
all of my arm I'm all symmetric the best
party we ever threw out from that walk
that awesome feeling of nervousness I
anticipation walking up to the door
crisp fall air
just got out of school journeys playing
God take me back so we get to the door
and we knock on the door and these
[__] who are at our house every
[__] weekend say sorry man we can't
let you in it it's too full yeah we were
like huh like it's too full now
meanwhile we live in a two-bedroom
apartment my boat me and my both my
brothers shared a bedroom my twin
brother and younger brother I never had
my own room but this was the closest I
got to my own room the entire time
growing up my twin brother brother and
younger brother shared bunk beds and I
had a twin bed right next to the buckman
that's the closest ever got to have my
own room was not your own bad it wasn't
attached that's right it physically was
not touched but you know what there's so
much love when you're around people that
close I told dog wouldn't trade it for
the world like Phi if I became a
gazillionaire and I had kids up like
babe were put them all in the same
goddamn room some of the weapon build my
minds of my life were at night laughing
with my brother right bedrooms cousins
coming over to sleep he the best times
in my life absolutely I think after I
you know I battled depression and some
bad breaks as an adult and I think what
I came to realize was some of the best
times I ever had I didn't realize it at
the time right so now I'm very conscious
of that and that's one of that's really
the probably the logic behind this
podcast is they have people open up
their eyes and go bro you're living the
good times right now yeah you're there
yeah so yeah it's hard to take in it
really is even they talk about like even
with supports they talk about as you're
going through a championship season you
really it just doesn't feel like that
until you're done it's accomplished then
you look back then you're like wow look
what we did so when you go I think about
stuff like that all the time some of the
best times were in those bedrooms and
stuff but so you know we're in a small
ass house that's always packed every
weekend and people knew how to get in
like you just hopped up on the roof you
could slide one window up and they'd be
there at your party whether you want
them or not even there we came home for
my grandmother's one night I walk in I
go what the [__] are you all doing
there's like ten people now sorry I'll
Derek let us in I said oh I said I'll
did he Derek come here and in my
walks up like how dare Glee I'll Todd
led us in I go really Todd come here I
said none of us let you in don't [__]
do that [__] again so it's always packed
so now they do it all the time it's
always packed and we can't believe they
just told us we can't come to their
[__] party here at our house that's
so insulting in so instead of getting
angry we decided we were going to get
even and I said everybody get in the car
we all drove to the corner liquor store
got a pay phone called the police as an
anonymous call and said I live right
across from me these parents are gone
these kids are tearing this house up
right now there's a lot underage
drinking I'm just concerned I don't want
anyone to get hurt concerned citizen its
all I am here I'm not I'm not yelling
about [__] these get I'm concerned for
their safety and we just [__] drove
around for like another half hour and we
did a loop by some [__] all the cars
are gone and we pulled up we've got back
of the door he said how about now can we
come in and you can see that Norton I
shown up with beer what the party got
busted [__] call that party out and
nobody was left like a motor parts like
what they're at you're a thing we used
to do too we'd have won we'd have people
over in the winter especially because we
had to hang outside a lot yeah and it's
[__] cold cold and you come inside I
remember having golf yeah Country Club
beers we'd sneak onto a golf course we
would leave the keg outside it was the
best plate we pack store and beer store
beer and bushes all winter long winter
long nice and cold so we would take
jackets when people would come in and if
you are an [__] you didn't get your
jacket back that was a rule like maybe a
drunk person fight and [__] you don't
get your jaw so you go home without your
jaco bring it to school we're not gonna
steal it will break almost so many great
ideas for movies and memories um would
you guys stash beer all over town oh man
we would stash it in bushes yeah stash
it like back in if there's somebody had
a little bit of woods in their backyard
we got action in the woods all winter
and you pack it in snow you know you had
to get it before it melted but we try to
get it we had one time man I can't
believe this dude did this and now I
think about it's like man I could have
been expelled or whatever but we had had
a party and
moosehead beer was just like a new hurry
yeah that was a big deal do we used to
go to ocean city every year in our one
like thing we could get was a t-shirt
yes okay and buckwheat surf shop yes ron
jon surf shop with weed says hotel we
says otay would be bombers down there in
our armors yeah yeah I remember that
spot we would want a BB bombers was too
cool exploit it IRA meeting the guy that
inspired those buckwheat shirts really
yeah it was a surfer down one buck we
know there was a dude down there was a
surfer dude Ocean City Maryland went off
they all loved oceans full surfers made
that they had a skate park right there
the ocean city bowl yeah there's two
kids from there that were tattooed
brothers that would skate mount
trashmore there was a deal's a kid that
uh my I'll never forget my cousin's tell
me they grow up in Highlandtown tell me
that there was this kid we should go to
this little Greek these Greek dudes
owned it was a spa called sport elite
and it was the best soccer store in
Baltimore I mean these dudes were on
point had everything they knew what was
up and out back in this little [__]
space they had built this halfpipe we
were like that's kind of weird yeah well
my cousins used to telling me this kid
from Highland town was this professional
skater and he's to skate back there and
we used to watch him know I like to and
it and damn if it was bucky lasek Wow
LASIK was that kid back there and he
skated there and he is a big Oriole guy
they state they used to say he would
skate all around I'm like I don't think
there's any professional skater for a
good well you let it live in California
or something I remember bucky lasek out
of baltimore's big even on his website
he has Oriole [__] he's loves it so cool
um so yeah I mean I told this story
before I'll tell it on this podcast he's
one of the favorite and I hope I'm not
repeating myself no it's the best one of
the favorite things that my brother and
I so we had a bedroom together and my
little brothers was right next to ours
this was before my parents got divorced
this is when we lived in the perfect
house and their glory here is great and
glorious and I wonder if that's common
with people like I can look back on my
childhood
I'm like oh yeah that house was awesome
yeah and I go back sort of fellow you go
back and tour I do when I go [__] yeah
although i did a podcast last year at my
little league field you did one of my
buddies that lived down the street and
it was uh I don't know man there's
something about looking at yesterday
that just makes me happier to be in the
net I don't know it's just something
that's the greatest original like this
is your life and I'm like I remember
being a two-year-old in that spot and I
remember being six here and I remember
being eight there I remember like I just
remember well I remember like my brother
you know you've got a human being that's
the four minutes older than you that's
growing up in the bed literally that's
why i always say fraternal twins and
identical twin beds like he is right
there next to me and in their nights
where I'm trying to fall asleep and I
would feel like I'd start feeling
something hit my face and that I hear
him like just laughing hysterically to
himself I'm like dude what are you doing
he's like I'm picking my nose and
rolling bogies of you with [__]
that's lucky that's what brothers are
for haha he's hit me with a bad stop so
uh and he used to be I want to sit down
and talk to him about it too cuz there's
stuff like his wife will tell me
something she's like your brother told
me the story and I'm like oh my god I
forgot about like I see if it's real if
he remembers that I don't invite yes
there was this best my mom was just you
know not a nice lady and um she just
wanted [__] the way she wanted it just
to be nasty sometimes so she had our
door cracked okay cracked to where she
wanted it and we didn't want it to be
that cracked so we opened it a little
more and she came over and was like I'm
gonna beat your ass leave this door
cracked don't you get out of bed again
I'm gonna beat your ass yeah okay here's
six per hour we're in seventh grade
sixth grade okay and we're like all
right so we just we and we were not
scared at all I'm okay here's the rules
we can't get out of bed again to open
that door anymore how we gonna get that
door open without getting out of bed
I call nightly have a chat no we had in
the closet we had a bunch of old fat
laces and I tied all of those fat laces
together and we tied it to the doorknob
and we laid it our beds we forked it off
he had what I had what we would lay in
bed we would just pull that door up she
like goddamn it and she come she then
don't get out of that bend we would let
it go cuz she couldn't feel it when she
pulled again she couldn't feel it yeah
and as long as it didn't latch which she
never did we just lay in bed and we
laughed and kept poor diet and she would
be looking and watching the double digit
cheat steal our see here we want us but
she was get piss too ah that's awesome
and then there was times to where i
would i would i'm quoting run away where
I tell my brother tell her I left and I
was just hide in the closet then she
would get a little brother oh you all be
sorry you'll be sorry when I run away
yeah and I [__] what hide in the
closet and then she would get my little
brother and take her out in a car and
then we'd have like a half hour to play
[__] donkey kong and [__] without
being yelled at yeah I think I was here
the whole time oh I don't know why he
told you that yeah it was the best times
they were good even when even I'm still
even after like after my father died if
we didn't have our friends around like
it would just I don't know where I'd be
like that [__] was it was so much fun to
have those people around and that their
parents were cool enough to let him stay
and [__] like that like it made a
[__] difference and we we had epic
[__] Nintendo tournaments and [__]
like our game was a little league world
series I haven't played that one I've
talked about this before on mine and
people sent me screen grabs of these
still out there isn't an amazing podcast
listeners how cool they are yeah by the
way I want to give a shout out to my
buddy Malcolm in Toronto for the Garbage
Pail Kids I hooked up sickler with a
path Thank You Malcolm in Toronto I love
him I got a I got a great pack of him
right here I love sharing the wealth
somebody tends to be something cool like
to hook up a pie thank you um what was a
huh you were talking about little league
world series little league world series
so that was like the
the everybody would get involved you all
had a team from wherever around the
world and um Jaime little Jaime on
Mexico this kid could be was though he
was like throw Heat it was like Fernando
he was the like the Babe Ruth he could
crush the ball that's awesome so one
night and I mean we would have did get
heated if needed people get out bro
video games bring out the best and the
worst in people so there's one night and
I still talk to my friend we just talked
about this a couple weeks ago because
i'll go do you remember her like [__]
you so we're going at it and we're in
like I honestly don't remember it's like
inning 19 or 20 ok we are tied up we
have been tied up and he has the bases
loaded with two outs okay and is loaded
two outs tigon tiger okay and he is the
home team so this hit ends at all and I
always always always always would press
even if it was a base hit I would always
throw to first anyway always I just did
and everyone's watching no one could
believe how far ago now the people that
don't even give a [__] that work was
like oh my god and he loops one into a
base hit into right field and he drops
the control he's like yeah well I always
always online always throw to first base
and I threw the first base and all of us
heard oh and I said oh my god oh my god
I got you he's like what the [__] mirror
well I got a whole way you like the
computer just I have algorithms like to
the you can play in fundamentals you're
going to get to this day he calls it a
dusty chip he said that mother [__]
Nintendo had a dusty chip in a bit Oh
big face it he was drop it like he was
okay cocky kid I threw that [__] the
first I thought it was over and I heard
out and it was the slow catcher it was a
matter and I [__] up God sure I got him
and I went up the next inning got two or
three runs and then he couldn't catch up
and I ended up winning that [__] game
we I mean it was the better can we still
talk about that and he I still I still
had them up I beg what's up man Dusty
chip call me back at night and I'll ship
you know you gotta do one year when you
have your sitcom and sitcom money you
just throw it around for all those dudes
that came by you gotta get old school
nintendo shirts that just say does [__]
well it got out of control like we
started playing then the Sega Genesis
came out we started playing NHL hockey
and um you know we would have crazy
tournaments for it we ended up making
like now you can go to the store and buy
like a WWF belt but we may want out of
foil and cardboard great and if you were
the champion you got to happen the
buckle like Ric Flair you got to take
that [__] dude and there was one night
where maybe just the concept of a
heavyweight we were the shoulder walking
around how is he ever like there's
something just so funny about it like if
you don't understand how great that is I
don't know if we could be friends I
watched two guys when we lived in our
own apartment this is in our 20s we were
24 yeah 23 24 I go to UPS I'll shout out
the UPS Baltimore primary one Joe Avenue
I go to UPS to work and I do the
overnight shift why I called my brother
on my break I'm like what's going on
he's like man Greg and deion got into a
fight I go and this was over this was
over coach cases college basketball is
Erica I go what do you mean I guess greg
was beating him so bad talking [__] if
finally got home they got into a
fistfight I'm calling from work here in
the two grown 20 year olds 20-some year
olds are fist-fighting still over
PlayStation but my friend that I beat in
Little League World Series his name's
shelor he always talk [__] like you he
would talk [__] but then you'd have that
one game where you're beating them like
12 22
you just throw the control down they
call me when you're not a play that's
what he would say like dad call me when
you know how to play have two goals he
couldn't take it so one night he had to
belt uh-huh and he had a younger brother
to Cory sup coy and Cory's about same as
my younger brother almost about three
and a half years okay he's like hey can
i play you for the belt and chris is
like yeah you can play before the bell
well it was Buster Douglas Mike Tyson
that night he passed Buster Douglas want
and scheeler got pissed his parents are
upstairs sleeping this is he's in
college his brothers in high school and
their fist fighting because chris took
the belt ripped it had my house before
he was going to give it a [__] up to and
i remember the controller's getting
swung and my brothers meant my little
brother smashing my big brother in the
face when they had Thea and enables ya
taiba smack like if full-on face choking
with coils people's like dad fights to
the death shogun people out making
noises like Luca Brasi market whenever
my mom like Marc you're gonna kill him I
want him I wanna kill his mother [__]
so his dad comes down the stairs in like
boxers and he sees his two kids fight
and he just goes down he didn't say a
word he rips the console out of the wall
rips it out of the wall and takes it
upstairs and throws it in the closet and
they never get to play it at home again
Wow he calls us up he's like hey man can
we come over mike jones and i was like
bring yours he's like a cat manic we
tells us the whole throw in the closet
that we were laughing sorry then we had
to make another belt and [__] cuz he got
all pissed off pleased to have great
[__] tournaments like that the
greatest and just stuff getting taken
from you i forgot that home we talk [__]
til you have to have thick skin goes out
I'll do stuff like where we debt that
whole mob scene that night we were all
so amped and up we decided to play a
madden tournament mm-hmm and we're in
this tournament and I it's double
elimination so that takes a [__]
while well this one dude the talks lost
[__] kicks it off to mrs. the opening
play of the game it comes right to me
and I see a seam and I hit the seam and
all I have to do now
push the controller up to have my guy
running the end down so i turn my back
to the screen Brandon without looking
dude ER doc here the best like you
remember playing kickball and you knew
you had a home run and then people would
like crawl yeah over home plate a
moonwalk over home plate or hop on one
foot to home plate or do the
Frankenstein ever walk someone else feel
humiliated somebody yeah it's good stuff
do you have time to tell the Preakness
fight story yeah but you have to go okay
I'll tell the previous flight story so
after all the debauchery of the day and
that final race is run you go back to
your bus and you waiting for everybody
to get back to your bus now you remember
you're waiting on people that something
do it a second summer do a mushroom some
drinking liquor in the hot Sun so we're
back and i'd say maybe at this point I
don't know it's a quarter of the people
that are supposed to be on the bus right
now I'm on my two brothers are on and
it's all grown-ups right not like 15 no
these are all of age legal drinking you
know adults the one per and my cousin
his sister the one who's not on is his
brother Gary now Gary also side note is
almost like ninety percent deaf so he
wears hearing aids and [__] which comes
into play later but anyway so we're
parked right next to another bus full of
and it's right here as close as this
wall as though of strangers that we
don't know right you know the other bus
that we do know is parked a couple buses
away from us okay two of us that went
nutso mini you know caravan down this
bus right here is full of nothing but
angry people I mean they're drunk and
they're [__] pissed and probably lost
a lot of money or maybe or they're all
they're all college age I would say and
they're [__] pissed and you start
seeing them argue amongst each other I
mean we're right here watching them
they're this close and you see this one
guy in this one girl get up on the bus
and the bus is full at this point and
then that bust
goes to an angry again like a little
angling mile inside you feel a building
bro you feel vibes and they threw that
dude and that chick off them I mean
violently like through them headfirst
out of the bus over the two steps that
you step up on my account of the [__]
ground and we're like holy fog why'd
they do that at that point we're like
don't look at their own business [__]
sit here and shut up let's get our
people on this yet mind your own
business that's not happening we got one
[__] dick on the bus I never liked
this [__] kid ever an [__] [__]
is he didn't like me for no reason and
for that reason I couldn't [__] stand
him yeah and he's in no shirt and shorts
she's like [__] you don't hit a woman I
go you don't hit a woman but you know
what you don't get on that [__] bus
by yourself and go lecture that [__]
boss about it right they just threw
people that they know off of loving
finally what do you think they're gonna
do you [__] that I'm going over there
everyone on our bus is telling him don't
[__] go over there well he's just
starting a problem he goes over there
and these people see him get off of our
bus so you know what the people that are
lined up with us start doing to us
because it sucked it's warm and they
start spitting in our [__] windows
they're spitting so now we're putting
our [__] windows up okay cuz they're
spitting this kid his name's Joe Joe
gets on the [__] bus and it was like
an animal the bus became like this
[__] animal so he got on and he
walked we kept seeing him he walked him
he's halfway down into the bus now he's
now he's three quarters of the way out
of the bus and as soon as he is they all
jumped on him and they [__] him up I
mean punching kicking whatever grabbed
him by the hair drug him to the the
[__] bus and threw him out of the
[__] steps his nose I don't know if
you ever seen Ben Roethlisberger that
night he got a busted nose hello de nada
hit him and broke his nose it was pushed
to the side of space us this dude knows
his push to the side his face now
they're getting off the bus and they
start attacking our bus and they're
beating our windows and shattering our
windows our bus drives a woman she is
[__] screaming she's scared she's
calling for help they're [__] him up
on the ground
were these the ducky boys from The
Wanderers you see that movie yes i have
this prairie and we I end up I feel bad
for this guy they're [__] this guy up
he's kind of not far from where I am I
popped the back door open I also up I
grabbed him by the wrist I drag drag
across gravel and no shirt on and [__]
his nose is pushes face I get him back
on the bus now my cousin's want to get
out and [__] fight we're still
waiting for one cousin I'm like no one's
getting off this [__] bus like it is
mayhem out there they're [__] people
just punching each other Jesus watching
it I'm up elevated up out of my bus
looking so now who are they fighting
who's that angry that's fighting anyone
that's walking by who random people that
are giggle Joe gets his ass beat but now
you drag your wounded back onto your
buck that's right now your bus itself
can its you got the doors closed now and
you're on your boss that's what I'm
fighting from your bus where's your
female bus driver she's in her seat
screaming okay yelling for hello
everybody be on the bus at this no no
there's still only a quarter of the
people that are supposed but that's all
Joe Lee kinda safely because their
shattering Oliver I mean they shattered
all the windows down the side right side
but there's also people that don't know
what's going on that are coming to our
body this way there's also people that
are on the bus on the other side of
these people that have nothing to do
with these people trying to get to their
bus and they're pulling people in the
middle of these two buses wrong place
wrong time here comes my cousin and you
know he's Baltimore City he's not
sweating it he starts throwing shots at
people I'm reaching out the window and
I've got a hold of the top of his hair
I'm like it the [__] up here now this
lady's gonna leave the [__] up here so
he gets up on the bus he can't hear us
at first were screaming yet cuz he's
deaf Harry ki gotta grab his hair get
the [__] up on the bus he gets on the
bus we're sitting there now all my
family is safe on this bus ok and now
the police are coming and they're pepper
spraying that's all dude they're pepper
spray my body in here everybody and this
woman is screaming y'all I get your
deposit back that's what she kept
yelling Derek dude she [__] date the
police clear laying her she took off
this bus was [__] up she left almost
all the people that were on that bus and
they had to pack on like they were
sitting in the rows and Isles on that
other bus
back in a park and ride and when we got
off and saw the damage them on the side
of it up the windows are all those dude
I don't know who we were but it's the
that's the scariest [__] I've ever
[__] seen I've scary and that dude
that didn't like me who think jalan like
you're [__] what thank you you dick
none of that needed to happen no they
were some people that's the only way
they learn that's it they threw those he
a better pace better person after that
or more idea i doubt it I'm sure he's
still piece of trash I just remember
everybody fought in middle school but
then by the time we got to high school
and people could really get hurt was a
different game yeah and this was college
so it's even different yeah it's amazing
how fragile dalka p I don't know man I
don't understand that about life like do
you ever like see like people scrap and
everybody's okay like oh really go at it
and somebody might have a black eye or
but they're good and then there you hear
those stories about a dude that got hit
once and he like tripped and hit his
head yeah that was it dead done so it's
like we're gonna happen like that it's
never its unless your life's on the line
it's just never worth it no never never
worth it what if we just ended it there
so good time spice this has been a great
time she did this episode was
unbelievable well thank you this is
exactly what I needed I appreciate I
needed this to man I feel better after
these hangouts dude thank you you know i
love you i love you too I gotta get Jay
on here I reached out to him because you
cuz I was afraid he wouldn't want to do
it so funny what he was like why uh-huh
cuz the feast is such a good podcast
well thank you where can people find
that and um go to the crab feast com
it's on iTunes it's on stitcher you can
also if you're not in itunes or iphone
user you can stream right from the
website on your android and stuff like
that oh that's all i gotta figure out
how to do that that's awesome and what
shows you have coming up what's what's
coming up new with you Larson and I are
doing a storytelling show at nerdmelt
together actually awesome never done
before you can go I can't remember the
exact date and time
it's coming up though I think early
October go to the crab feast calm for
that and you can go to Ryan sick without
confronting my dates and it's your 12
mins twitter Oh Ryan Sickler Twitter are
at Twitter Facebook is Ryan Sickler
official someone else got me on that one
thank you Ron thank you dude I love it
I think you fix the headphones sound
better guys that's Ryan Sickler please
check him out on Twitter Facebook if you
ever seem at a comedy club he destroys
suddenly I can't wait for you to hear
that episode that's ago I know I've
heard I've seen Ryan i saw i speaking of
saw him with Macbeth and quarter
flappers oh my god sets double trouble I
was it was a great show we gotta get
Nick back on here oh yeah there's such a
good crew out here of just good funny
talented people I've haven't seen Mick
do an hour I would love and I haven't
seen him doing out what I did a I did an
hour a year ago at the Hollywood improv
and I got Mick do one of the spots on
her yeah yeah it was originally so
awesome he has a great podcast it's it's
it is so great with so much comedy
nowadays how like you get all all this
extra content mm-hmm and I'm just
thinking about that though doing an hour
in la that'd be really cool especially
maybe even do with a podcast do like
people talking guys come in there's just
so many different ways now you don't
have to have fun yeah just to go out and
it's especially with movie prices going
up it's like going is comedy it's not
even it used to be all well it's to
expect it's now it's if you're not
drinking booze okay if you're not
drinking booze you're good and even if
you do it I'm one of the weird ones it
just doesn't really drink anywhere most
people gonna go drink after the movie
anyways yeah yeah it's so expensive to
have fun it really is but but then i but
then again i got podcast for free yeah
thanks a good advertisers like ink
advertising company for all your t-shirt
poster and sticker needs its ink adco
com is that a good one guys Bryce's body
owns that company in there good company
yeah they are cuz and then the t-shirts
came out awesome you can get them at all
some Steve com I gave one the Sickler
because he thought it was so cool oh
that's nice yeah they are the I have the
I saw someone posted a picture with your
with your sticker on forget I figured it
was it Mary on her scooter and I was
next to Brody Stevens sticker exactly
that's what it was that so that's so
cool and I see it all over the country
in the world now
yeah it's insane so also speaking about
all over the world I owe my buddy in
Kuwait a care package because Don Carlos
gave me a surprise for him and then I
have a surprise for him I was about to
say what it was but I was like oh I know
is listening oh no you don't want to
really know you don't want to ruin the
surprise it makes it funner I I was
thinking we take is on the way in for
recording this earlier in the week yeah
I think it's better this way right but
then sometimes I forget stuff right
that's true but it is fun and then today
is the second day of rosh hashanah like
a big jewish holiday happy new year
buddy thank you very loose ins but I
called and I got the phone passer on the
table thing it took like 20 minutes Oh
adorable all the aunts and uncles and
cousins and is this when I blow the
shofar the ram's horn is that new years
ooh I think they do I think it's mostly
during Passover but I think they do
right now if it's not this week then
isn't it's like about Adam and even
stuff Linda I don't think so maybe I
haven't been in so many years so yeah
there could be some Jews who were very
upsetting me right now it's mostly like
saying like you you're supposed to
apologize to everyone who you've wronged
over the year and i'm glad i got an
apology from call out yesterday if you
really yeah i got mad at somebody i
never get mad at somebody but they kept
on making fun of me and if you keep on
getting made fun of your gonna latch
back yeah but what I forget is that I
use words for a living and I could say
really mean things are chicken came
comedians be a lot better look at you
know because you think comedians be
funny and not be good be good at being
mean but I go my God if you use your
super it's like being a Jedi use it for
good or bad do you probably would you
practice as a young comic like-for-like
hecklers is that one now or they just
know it's just because your brain thinks
so fast I'm are able to like you know
when you were able to think of something
funny yeah you're like oh that's like
this you know you go you look like but
Papa when you can do that for funny you
can also do that for me and I said some
meat but if you make fun of me for four
hours in a row and I keep on telling you
to stop but I still feel bad so it's the
same way if somebody pushed me and I
punched him in the face that happened
once and I
really hurt the kid and I've even though
he started I felt terrible [__] what
brothers fighting like they're poking
you poking you and you lose you lose any
punch them again you feel terrible right
it's almost like I don't know where that
line is but I feel bad and I hope my
buddy forgives me I'm sure if you
apologized you I mean that's the whole
point of of the holidays you're supposed
to start the new year with the first
late and yes I tweeted that out this
weekend that there's nothing one of the
best things in life and I'm the more i
think about it might be the best thing
in life is another chance that's
interesting yeah think about that I
think it really is another chance to do
better to make up for bad or to even try
I saw the cutest thing and then we'll
end it on this because it really was
like so cute I can't even believe I
witnessed it what happened so yesterday
I went in for this audition and it was
awesome because like it would be playing
a parent and I was like well if I can't
be one in real life maybe I could be one
on TV and there's all these little kids
they're like that like in the glory age
like 34 years like three year old girl
there was this little three-year-old
girl with playing with him I pretty
ponies oh maybe she was four but then
she saw this little boy actor kid I
think she knew on the other side of the
room oh really and she was like mom I
should go say hi to him I should go say
hi to him and she was like looking
sweetie if you want to say in the little
girl was so cute so anyway she starts go
like this like you like moving her arms
like psyching herself up like she looked
like Ric Flair walking to the ring she
was like moving her arms like this and
she was like gonna go say hi you're
gonna go see go say hi and then she took
like five steps and she was like but
you're not gonna do it today and she
turned around it was I was like don't
worry sweetie I do that all the time on
a friday night like it hanging out with
my buddies I'm about to go say hi to my
wife and then I'm like damn wait till
next time because I always think it's
like the scene in Good Will Hunting
remember when Rob Williams talks about
seen his wife for the first oh yeah I'm
like this is this is the night we're
both gonna remember forever and you just
go into it around yak you know I always
lose courage and you could cuz I've
never once I don't like at a bar unless
I was really waste ringing a lot said it
like talk to anybody like that
but it would be funny to see like a
four-year-old just go through the entire
process what made it so cute so it was
the funniest cute not like laugh at but
I just related like I hate when people
laugh at little kids I wasn't laughing
at her but it was just really really
cute so then this other girl that was on
the audition was closer to the little
girl and she was like did you hear what
she said before she took the first step
but I want no cuz a little kid had
already left so so before she took her
first step this what she said to herself
be brave how cute is that how cute is
that you shouldn't got the little boy
and brought him over oh man so cute it's
hard especially little kids like I had a
little cousin who would cry every time
anyone left not even at her yeah cuz
they're sensitive but it's not even it's
not like you it's just when you see
something that cute like sometimes the
reaction is just to laugh yeah you're
like this is the best thing in life yeah
hanging out with family be braids old
people dogs oh my gosh the Children's
Hospital in others these special dogs
that show up these special therapy dogs
that everybody gets to go over in pet
how much time do you spend petting the
dogs oh so much and then there's just
one giant dog and you know his name is
what Clyde how great is that dog is he I
don't know he's giant huge in locust
he's that you like the I can't even
believe he's not he's real all those
like therapy dogs always like what you
would hope your dog would be just just
sits there like legs you pat them and
just yes they're smiling and yes but
growing up we always had dogs that was
like poop in the house and bark and
needed too much attention look is
although the good dogs always trained
and no one wants a trailer it takes a
lot of effort to train a dog I just like
when they jump on me are excited to see
me yeah yeah I'm not gonna train them
yeah my dog would have its life together
just as bad as much as I have my live
together like winners always have like
winner dogs his name is Cesar and he
works off my hands commands and I'm like
really and they're always the people
that are like on the Paleo diet and do
CrossFit and and
I are going ted talks like there's this
commercial i think was like a fantasy
football commercial and it was like a
chubby dude with an english bulldog
right next to me eating snacks watching
football that's exactly what I want if
you heard dog what kind of dog do you
think you would be uh maybe like an
English or French Bulldog they are off
maybe before I was English Bulldog no
else can I've lost enough weight to
being a French Bulldog hopefully get to
MIT you are looking great slow and
steady wins the race I guess yeah yeah
it's just slow and steady doesn't gain
the weight back now you look great I
have to give to get back mom being
really strict about it I have to tighten
up my diet a little bit too i'm going to
domingos today with my buddy Mike pie
and I think we're gonna do a podcast
afterwards oh great cuz i figured to
mingos who put us in a good mood what
are you gonna get at domingos i don't
know because sunday was supposed to be
my cheat day okay but this is bad so
saturday night after church I knew that
Pizza Hut had a special it was ten bucks
for any pizza you want to carry out
bastards right don't tell Joey don't
tell Joey that I've in the fat guy again
little guy from Philly went to pizza
dough for ten bucks though it's like dog
food but it's only ten bucks I can't
wait I just called it doc I feel
terrible for saying that because it
wasn't that bad what was you into church
before yet so then I was like walking on
the church i'll start my cheat day or
but i just had that and then i had like
a couple cookies on sunday which is
supposed to be my cheat day but that's
all I did I didn't really overdo it
because I knew the eagles game was on
Monday yeah so then I had cheese steaks
with Jimmy schubert yesterday and now
I'm gonna have Domingo so it's kind of
like I did all the damage of one cheat
day but I'm spreading it out over a
couple days which isn't good but
normally on my cheat day I put the pedal
to the metal and like from midnight to
midnight its donuts chinese food pizza I
that that's when I started making like I
had a cheat day when I was after juicing
and I first used to just be like Sunday
like I wake up three meals on Sunday but
then I'm like well technically midnight
is still sunday so i guess i can have it
saturday night after mid yes and then
I'd be like well
what about cheat weekends yes you gotta
be careful and especially with football
it makes it tough there's an I know it's
all advertising but I miss having wings
and pizza just a wing in abuja haul junk
food sometimes good but i'll tell you
what i did get the nutribullet i'm
loving it can you put wings and pizza in
them no but I'm gonna just start trying
to eat super duper healthy I've been
doing pretty good except for these last
few cheat meals but other than that I'm
good as long as you're standing as long
as you're not putting on weight I feel
like that's Elina I want to lose my more
because I want to get a girlfriend annie
girl that likes me is gonna probably
that won't be because of what I look
like and and once you start dating
you'll start eating delicious food and
gain yeah would like that well health
he's good but I do like to cook I've
never met a girl in our line that likes
to cook that would be weird really most
of the other girls don't ya go to a
sushi and all that stuff and go out to
eat too much Paul made McCarron army
little bit she did yeah she made sauce
by herself was it good yeah it was
actually nice next time next time we're
gonna put some meat in it like it was
just she we just eat veggies mmm but it
was good it was good it was a I think
chicken parm might be one of my
favorites if not if not top it's
definitely times incredible now I go
domingos that's where I'm going buddy I
gotta get out of here when do Augustine
OHS podcast thank you guys so much for
listening take care god bless Lee give
him a shout out by everybody thank you
for listening good times that was a good
one
Wow
yesterday was such an easy game I'm a
bit
did they change
well
you